[Music]
after we have passed the Caspian Sea and
the Scythian ocean our course takes an
easterly direction such being the turn
here taken by the line of the coast the
first portion of these shores after we
passed the Scythian promontory is
totally uninhabitable owing to the snow
and the regions are joining our
uncultivated in consequence of the
savage state of the nations which dwell
there here are the abodes of the
Scythian anthropophagi who feed on human
flesh hence it is that all around them
consists of vast deserts inhabited by
multitudes of wild beasts which are
continually lying in wait ready to fall
upon human beings just as savage as
themselves after leaving these we again
come to a nation of these Citians and
then again to desert tracts tenant aid
by wild beasts until we reach a chain of
mountains which runs up to the sea and
bears the name of tabbies it is not
however before we have traversed a very
nearly one-half of the coast that looks
towards the northeast that we find it
occupied by inhabitants
[Music]
the first people that are known out here
are these saris so famous for the wool
that is found in their forests after
steeping it in water they comb off a
wipe down that adheres to the leaves and
then to the females of our part of the
world they give the twofold task of
unraveling their textures and weaving
the threads afresh so manifold is the
labor and so distant are the regions
which are thus ransacked to supply a
dress through which our ladies may in
public display their charms the sarazar
of inoffensive manners but Barangay
strong resemblance there into all savage
nations they shun all intercourse with
the rest of mankind and await the
approach of those who wish to traffic
with them the first river that is known
in their territory is this atheras next
to that the cam berry and the third the
Laros after which we come to the
promontory of christ the gulf of sahaba
the river at Janos and the nation of the
Attic Orry on the Gulf of that name our
people protected by their sunnyhills
from all noxious blasts and living in
the climate of the same temperature as
that of the hyper bourree they also
informed us that the side of their
island which lies opposite to India is
ten thousand stadia in length and runs
in a southeasterly direction but beyond
the imodium mountains they look towards
the Surrey whose acquaintance they have
made in their pursuits of Commerce that
the father of the righteous had
frequently visited their country and
that the Sara's always came to meet them
on their arrival these people they said
exceeded the ordinary human height had
flaxen hair and blue
eyes and made an uncouth sort of noise
by way of talking having no language of
their own for the purpose of
communicating their thoughts the rest of
their information was of a similar
nature to that communicated by our
merchants it was to the effect that the
merchandise on sale was left by them
upon the opposite bank of a river on
their coast and that it was removed by
the natives if they thought proper to
deal on terms of exchange on low grounds
or luxury with greater reason to be
detested by us than if we only transport
our thoughts to these scenes and then
reflect what are its demands to what
distant spots it sends in order to
satisfy them and for how mean and
unworthy an end
[Music]
[Music]
you